hello and welcome to this video playing
lunatic ex so Peter mashaallah grant
ptime shalik ok check again GM ok so
it's not around him ok now we place
probably some Slav ok skype messages
yeah ok so III here this is an
interesting move water ok goes for g6
this is a line that I sometimes play
it's a simple line okay 95 hmm that's
quite unusual really black as happy to
take with the pawn for a typically Slav
type position but ok 95 cannot be
absolutely terrible if it takes now go
see six that's a very solid position
f5 okay yeah I guess he probably wants
to after d takes he wants to play 97 but
I go d5 anyway yeah this looks like
white should be a little bit better here
this position I've got nice control that
over d5 and he has to be somewhat modest
tienes and his ideas let's see Queen
there mmm yeah Bishop d two bishops III
would be cool yeah wonder if he people
take on be too it's very likely actually
mmm but I don't I don't really see great
alternative so I have to allow that he
has to take now almost I mean otherwise
I just go bishops III Adam comfortably
better maybeee form that's also an
option opening up its diagonal but I
don't think rook the aid or something
yes sir it's good that's it just feels
very passive
you had this one hmm interesting i can
go bishops III you which is a little bit
better for me or just go back to be
three I mean there should be three looks
like the logical move there this
pressure on f7 is good you have played
this guy before his then dangerous with
his tactics but often I don't quite get
the strategic decision so this looks
very nice I think if I for them slightly
questionable move them okay Bishop c31
and I can go a form i wonder if i should
really pay much attention to that
pawn to e4 is also interesting that
maybe you will go to c6
yeah this is the most normal maybe I
should have played this just quicker
let's go here I know you can take but
after work t5 it also looks nice flight
yeah I think I'm going back I'm happy
about that i have this stable be three
position back for my bishop you can take
and go if orbit I don't mind it that
much this Bishop is still very strong on
b3 it's a lot stronger than its night
now it's not easy to play for black
efore is also be kiness so what's the
deal I mean isn't that good Queen have
six maybe I'll just rocked e71 group t7
as good as no queen bee three or
anything and I don't think so
okay let's develop and see what to do
now Quincy for maybe to attack a form it
doesn't really threaten that much
now probably rookie ate it probably will
be eight
don't see Luke c7 for the other look
maybe no don't have much time available
I'm ahead on the clock but still
also loop c6 is part of this now Roxy 6
ok so what's the deal here night h4
maybe also coming it's Jackie to flick
that check in and I definitely want to
trade here night h4 might be some color
to play and here that looks nice and
then time were attacking b6 he doesn't
have much how to play here
right so okay maybe back I don't know
back to and take be five yen okay he
wanted this is countess or some counter
play definitely okay and so I need some
space Jack good defense night comes to
see three here oh my god i have no time
check check check ah wow I completely
screwed that one up oh that's a shame
plague reasons well it's a shame after
black was essentially busted here didn't
didn't manage to put this away I should
put it away somewhere around here yeah
he played a couple of yeah come on IE
fibers just a bad move and after d5 what
is quite substantially better i think i
did it all right i mean i keep a very
nice advantage in the only thing I don't
win the game this is the thing I think
all is good up to here so let's c you c
6-r ook t5s the engines move with the
win yeah okay this also prevents night H
form maybe it was a bad idea to trade
Queens even though it is better for
white still
it it doesn't really keep this this much
pressure though it's about some some
precise moves here probably probably
this is wrong okay it's still a big
advantage but this is this is a problem
now probably FYI got nervous this is
still a lot better for white now yes no
good square for the night actually
something like that I go here and I
cover this and still go here yeah okay
so f for Jack he's ok now i'm here with
93 is bad I Abbott by now I have
completely lost the threat yeah it's a
bit of a shame yeah t he hold on in this
bad position not not losing immediately
a couple of decisions were really
questionable if I've is just a bad man
after which white is better that this
Bishop is just very strong while g7 is a
bad piece and this led to this use your
knowledge for white again it was all ok
I think probably if i go and route 25
now here 55 this looks very strong it's
it's very hard to even make a move with
black so this is still hanging and he
has no active move the computer wants to
play something that will be seven and
this is like plus 3 yeah that is the
most powerful one Jenny yeah this is may
be too cautious and open yeah the other
other continuation is better but ok you
can apply perfectly anyway in blitz ok
thanks for watching guys